[Music]
to the side
we're invited
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm doing the job today
Lola from Ukraine right yeah I'm gonna
show you guys some of her portfolio
she's a amazing model gonna show you
some of her poses and then what do we do
the client for today Maya oh just some
shopping okay yeah for the catalog and
you remember some of the brand names we
did today you're like like yuck
there's a popular brand here in South
Korea right oh it's very famous okay
in Colombia Colombia yeah that's famous
international just a Korean traditional
say it again nope Napa
yes no space no space all right that's
it
[Music]
what are you looking at right now male
model poses it's very fast it looks is
very weird right like your robot yeah
hey can I send Daniel I am the guy that
you were watching doing those weird
dance like moves model poses anyway if
you're new here to my channel welcome
subscribe click the belt so you won't
miss anything new and on this channel
you'll find anything that's got to do
with style grooming Fitness and modeling
life of course I've got some pretty cool
vlogs check those out now looking at
these videos yeah it looks very funny
alright looks weird it looks like a
dance looks like a kind of robot poses
but to do these poses really good in
each click you need to take an account a
lot of stuff it's not easy to take an
account everything that you need to
remember while doing the poses because
remember from the models perspective he
sees the photographer and he sees the
angles of the light so you need to
position yourself in sidon angles so
that you present the clothes in a really
good way
[Music]
[Music]
you need to remember your facial
expressions you cannot have the same
expressions all the time except if that
is where the client really wants but the
client wants to show a little bit of
character then you need to change it up
a little bit and then also you cannot do
the same kind of poses over and over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it guys see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]